we begin this morning with the frigid
and dangerous winter weather that
continues to grip the northern third of
the nation overnight whiteout conditions
made for treacherous driving in Billings
Montana several cars and trucks slid off
the roads and into ditches cold
temperatures and zero Degree wind chills
stretch from the northern and central
plains to the Great Lakes and into the
Northeast and are expected to last into
next week
Tony decouple is in bitter cold Bryant
Park here in New York we feel bad for
you Tony good morning good morning good
morning yeah that zero Degree windchill
is the reason why I am standing in front
of an ice sculpture right now but if you
can believe it this is actually nothing
compared to the deep freeze in many
other parts of the country where the
wind chill is making it feel as low as
34 degrees below zero coming in cars
coming in boom boom
just get home there's a big truck right
in front of us down in the ditch the
freezing temperatures turned us 31 in
Western Michigan into a skating rink
causing this 40 car pileup Friday cars
were kicking up the snow and which
created a whiteout and we believe
somebody lost control which started the
chain reaction sub-zero wind chills also
made going for a walk or a bike ride a
dangerous endeavor it's a challenge
waking up in the morning coming out and
come walking to work every day
especially in this weather in upstate
New York the cold weather transformed
this geyser into a towering ice volcano
while burying us we go under five feet
of snow since Christmas Eve it turned
out to be too cold for these thresher
sharks that went into shock and died
along Cape Cod and even too cold for the
st. Louis Winter Fest at the arch the
low temperatures forced the closure of
the holiday skating rink wellness checks
on seniors with no heat Tamika Rogers is
a caseworker with the Salvation Army in
Chicago she helps vulnerable senior
citizens you never know the situation
they can be in there freezing or they
can be in there doing very well and they
just don't want to be bothered it's
important because a lot of them don't
have the support Boston mayor Marty
Walsh looked forward to the city's New
Year's Eve celebration but had a warning
we're asking people to dress warm with
lots of loose layers we're asking you
also to keep watch out for signs of
hypothermia and frostbite in these very
cold conditions frostbite can happen in
as little as 30 minutes wall well many
New Year's Eve celebrations are going to
go on as plan the frigid temperature as
has forced a cancellation of others
including a fireworks show in Omaha
meanwhile Alex I'll let you know if this
fountain behind me starts melting
because it could be the first sign of a
much-needed
spring back to you Tommy put your
fingers back in those mittens I'm
worried about them don't need a :
Brighton Park in New York thanks Tony
stay warm